[Música]
y hablamos ahora de salud en directo
américa de france 24 más romero sala ya
está con nosotros en el estudio mar a
raíz del tiroteo de valiente ex a sigue
creciendo la preocupación por la
violencia de armas de fuego y cada vez
más son las cosas que pueden tomarlo
como un problema de salud pública por
quemar raúl o puede ser realmente es
porque no es un problema a tener pues a
no ver no porque son las armas de fuego
la muerte por armas de fuego perdón en
eeuu es la principal causa de muerte
entre los jóvenes de 20 a los 19 años en
este país la cifra además ha crecido un
83 por ciento desde el 2013 menos de una
década entonces por todos estos motivos
cada vez son más estas voces de expertas
que se unen para pedir que se trate como
un problema de salud pública para
explicarnos en qué consiste esto estamos
con el doctor oscar franco él es
profesor de epidemiología y de salud
pública de la universidad de berna
doctor muy buenos días gracias por
acompañarnos en este miércoles cuéntenos
por qué se puede considerar un problema
de salud pública y en qué consistiría
abordarlo de esta manera que
significaría
y antes que nada es un problema que no
solamente afecta a los eeuu un problema
que afecta a nivel mundial y es que
específicamente casi la mitad de los
muertes que ocurren por homicidios son
jóvenes entre los 15 y 29 años si
miramos en latinoamérica por ejemplo el
80 por ciento de los homicidios
ocurrieron por arma de fuego
afecta principalmente a la población
masculina en algunos países llega hasta
el 94 por ciento de las víctimas son
hombres y afecta principalmente países
como brasil como el salvador como
colombia panamá guatemala hasta ahora
esto se ha visto más que todo con un
problema de crimen sin embargo yo creo
que es esencial tomar un
abordaje diferente dentro del punto de
vista de salud pública un punto un punto
de vista que se ha basado en evidencia
que se ha basado en la ciencia y que nos
ayuda a entender por qué está ocurriendo
esto son conflictos violencia doméstica
feminicidios y robos inseguridad
quiénes son los que están falleciendo
quiénes son los que están cometiendo
estos homicidios cuáles son los factores
que permiten el acceso y luego poder
entender cuáles son las estrategias que
realmente funcionan no solamente por
sentido común sino basados en evidencia
científica y traducir esa xavi de esa
evidencia y esas estrategias en
políticas de salud en estrategias que
realmente ayuden a terminar la
legislación que pueda proteger a la
población
doctor lo saludo muy buena mañana no
todo tampoco son los tiroteos no que nos
dice las cifras sobre el uso de estas
armas de fuego y sus consecuencias
a nivel mundial más o menos el 50% son
homicidios 50 por ciento son suicidios
estos man siempre mientras que hay más
altos niveles de homicidio y menos
niveles de suicidio y eso depende de
karrika y de cada país luego en un
porcentaje más pequeño tenemos
accidentes que pueden ocurrir entonces
hay que mirar más allá del problema de
los tiroteos es tomar en cuenta que
necesitamos entender las causas del tipo
de violencia el tipo de
personas de las víctimas que están
siendo afectadas y cómo varía según las
regiones y esto es lo que nos podría
ayudar a entender las causas y las
circunstancias que están detrás de lo
que está ocurriendo y que nos podrían
ayudar a resolverlos doctor precisamente
hablaba de los suicidios una cifra muy
alta en estas proporciones de muertes
por arma de fuego que vinculó podemos
establecer entre la salud mental y este
acceso tan amplio a las armas de fuego
si generalmente se relacionado la salud
mental especie específicamente con los
suicidios pero también con los
homicidios y lo que ha tenido el impacto
de la pandemia y 19 la salud mental de
la población se cree que podría acelerar
que podrías hacer mucho más manifiesta
el problema a nivel mundial
sin embargo hay que entender que esto no
es solamente un problema de salud mental
si miramos solamente en los eeuu vemos
como la población afrodescendiente
tienen 21 veces mayor riesgo de fallecer
por homicidio
la población blanca a pesar de que la
población blanca son los que más tienen
acceso importan más armas entonces lo
que estamos viendo es es una relación
muy intrincada muy complicada de
factores sociales de oportunidades de
educación y
no solamente lo de salud mental sino de
aspectos sociales y bien de actividades
que se tienen que abordar desde ese
punto de vista de salud pública basada
en la evidencia doctor y precisamente
esta perspectiva de la salud pública le
quiero preguntar si se tienen medidas
que se puedan tomar para empezar a
prevenir estas muertes
y entonces lo primero es entender las
causas entender cuáles son las
circunstancias lo segundo ayudará a
tener unas políticas claras para
controlar el acceso a las armas sabemos
que la presencia de armas de fuego en un
hogar aumenta en un 41% la probabilidad
de muerte de una persona de la familia y
en más del 200 por ciento de entre las
mujeres entonces necesitamos políticas
también que sean basadas en los derechos
humanos en la igualdad de género y
también estrategias que se pueden
implementar a nivel de políticas de
salud pero también registros que puedan
determinar dónde están ocurriendo qué
tipo de violencia está ocurriendo y
cuáles son las víctimas que se están
afectando por estos homicidios doctoró
sólo para terminar le pedimos una
pequeña reflexión alrededor de por qué
es tan difícil entender que estas
muertes también se deben prevenir igual
que sucede por ejemplo con los
accidentes en las carreteras que después
de años de políticas públicas pues han
descendido tanto en muchos países
incluido en eeuu porque con el tema de
la regulación de las armas de fuego es
tan difícil de comprender
sí creo que la prevención históricamente
siempre se toma más tarde no se disemine
la importancia de la prevención pero
también porque no se ve ese impacto
global que tiene el problema por ejemplo
cuando estamos de armas nos hablando de
armas no solamente estamos hablando de
pérdida de vidas estamos hablando
también de un problema de contexto
social de inseguridad de deterioro en el
desarrollo económico y en problemas de
gobernabilidad entonces si se entiende
que esto es algo que está afectando no
solamente la población sino específica
que son las víctimas sino a nivel social
y a nivel de nación yo creo que se puede
tomar una unas medidas mucho más
efectivas y más preventive ojalá así sea
doctor muchísimas gracias como siempre
por estar con nosotros nuestro espacio
de salud en directo américa de france de
24 mar también muchísimas gracias por
acompañarnos ya saliendo de esta gripa
que la tenía atrapada ya nos está
acompañando nuevamente en el estudio
nosotros vamos entonces a saludar a
nuestro segundo invitado el día